and for sean newcomb be aggressive
attack the strike zone
and do what i think everybody thinks
you're capable of doing two balls two
strikes
and strike three at the knees nemo was
frozen that had some sinking action to
it
and shawn has his first strikeout two up
two down back-to-back singles
and it brings up matt adams and a base
hit for adams the other way
he beats the shift and freddie freeman's
going to score
ozuna around a third and the braves with
three straight singles
used the shift as a big weapon and it's
one to nothing in the first
and former met travis darno is coming up
pitch
smoked into center field that's down for
a hit it's two to nothing
four straight singles for atlanta this
one on a two-strike count
a chance to add to a two-nothing lead
here with two outs
and he comes in on swanson and gets him
swinging to retire the side three
strikeouts in the inning for
porcello works around a two out double
one hit one left
so one out of one on now jd davis he
hasn't found it yet he hasn't gotten on
track
and jd flies one out to left ozuna back
to the warning track
right back at the wall it's out of here
jd davis clears the yellow line for a
two run homer to tie up the game
he got just enough
second home run of the year for j.d and
it's two to two in the fourth
first and second and ciarte the batter
now
roll down to first alonzo gets the out
at second
the relay not in time garno advancing
the third on the play and now the batter
will be acuna with two outs
and acuna flies one out to center hit
pretty well but nimmo has room back in
right center
and he puts it away to retire the size
the fifth inning at
truest park in atlanta robinson canoe
will face the atlanta starter shawn
newcomb
and the curveball hit in the air to
right field acuna goes back takes a look
and that ball is out of here
robinson canoe parks one into the seats
in right field
for his first home run of the year and
the mets go in front three to two
i can't tell you the number of times
i've seen robinson canoe do that get a
lefty curveball
and hit it out of the ballpark just like
that well a tough spot here for
julius chassine whose base is loaded and
the league's home run champ
in the batter's box and he takes the
walk and that'll tack on a run and it's
4-2 new york and now conforto hold for
his last nine
3-2 to conforto and he tries to hold did
he go he did not all
four and enforces in another run now
we'll bat with the bases loaded
and suspended rockets one in the left
field for a base hit
that ball will roll to the line jimenez
is in
nimmo is in and the mets get two on a
double by uh suspenders
to go up seven to two there's your two
out rbi gary and here's robinson canoe
the tenth man to bat in the inning
and robbie rockets one of the right
field for a base hit
that'll bring in conforto cespedes will
be held to third as acuna gets the one
hop strike to the plate
the mezza put up a sixth spot and lead
eight to two
and it brings up matt adams an rbi hit
for matt
on the ground that is a fair ball past
alonso and headed for the corner
dansby will score freeman on his way to
third
matt adams with an rbi double and the
braves
trim the lead to eight to three let's
see what darno can do
he's singled walked ripped into right
field that's gonna get down for a base
hit that'll score one more
freeman comes home around the rosie
greets ahmed rosario who's hole for
three
it's this next pitch in the air pretty
deep to left field down the line if it's
fair it might
go and it is a home run a home run for
ahmed rosario he tucked it just inside
the foul pole
in the left field corner rosario's first
home run of the year
it ends an over 11 streak and the mets
tack on a run
now lead it 9-5 so dansby's the hitter
hitting second because ozzy got the
night off
hit hard toward right conforto retreats
that ball's over his head and off the
wall
dansby's on his way to second streaking
around his ender he's going to come
around and score
it's a 10-6 game a ringing double off
the wall
by dansby swanson
one-two coming and that's rocking it
into the glove of jimenez
what a play side retired
ximena is showing the hops and taking a
basement away from ozuna potanzas has
the first out here's dansby
1-1 pitch line drive right field a base
hit here comes echeveria around third
they're gonna wave him conforto's throw
is way off the line and another
big hit for dansby swanson second and
third with one out for freddie freeman
who's ahead in the count
nowhere near a wild pitch ender's coming
home throw to the plate is going to be
late and ciarte scores the umpires are
going to take a look at this
and he is safe so that'll take a two-out
hit from travis darno the former met
he's had a good night two rbi singles
live drive in a right center field base
hit one run scores
two run score ozuna to third darno to
second
he's coming right
clears them with a double to the right
center field gap
braves are a strike away martin ready
here we go high fly ball right field
drifting back acuna warning track has
rove and the braves complete the
comeback
what an unbelievable game